is it aesthetic?
but is it authentic?
also no
but is it fkn delicious
comfort food with seven hidden vegetables
that serves six
For less than $5 each?
yes, yes it is
and at risk of really pissing off the Italian community
this is how I make my lasagna
nobody ever actually taught me how to make lasagna
so this could be all wrong
this is just one of those recipes that I figured out when I first became a mum
in a pan pop onion and garlic saute until soft and translucent
into that I'm adding mushroom
courgette carrot and capsicum
then I add a kilo of my beef mince and
season generously with kelp salt
mixed herbs smoked paprika
cumin and pepper then I add some of this yeast spread
which is totally optional
but I do find it gives the heartier flavour
I also add Worcestershire sauce
balsamic vinegar and a can of tomatoes
you wanna let that simmer and reduce for as long as you possibly can basically
or for as long as you've got time for
then I get started on my cheese sauce so I begin with a roux made of butter
flour and milk I'm actually using oat milk cause we didn't have any cow's milk
which is why the milk's not super white but either way
it still tastes the same to me
and in goes the cheese
and when you've got your cheese sauce to the right consistency
it's time to put your lasagna together
using fresh lasagna sheets
so these are already oven ready
I just start layering my mince
my cheese sauce and my pasta
and I do this as many times as I can with the ingredients that I have
and when I'm on to my final layer
I top it all with some grated mozzarella cheese
cover with tin foil so we don't burn that top layer of cheese
and pop it in the oven when it's about halfway done
I do take that tin foil off so the top can become nice and golden
let it stand for a couple of minutes before slicing and serve it
this is such an easy family friendly dish and a guaranteed crowd pleaser
as always you can find the recipe down below